first though let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you starting with
the guardian it describes the impact of
earthquakes which have killed thousands
in turkey and Syria as catastrophic the
Metro tomorrow morning pictures a young
girl being pulled alive from a building
in Syria their headline reads saved from
Quake hell the mirror has the same photo
described in the rescue as a moment of
Hope amid the horror the sun has a
simple plea help them and even the
financial times leads with news of the
earthquake away from the earthquake
pollsters are suggesting Liz truss's
comeback has hurt the conservative party
that's according to the eye tomorrow
morning The Daily Mail says generals and
MPS are warning that Britain could be
left defenseless if military is not
given more funding in the next budget
and the Daily Star warns of half-term
holiday chaos due to weights for
passports
and of course a quick reminder for you
that by scanning the QR code that you'll
see on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch with us well as
we say we're joined tonight by Peppa
Korea and Harry Cole very good evening
to you both and let's start with the
news of course it's a very Bleak very
sobering headlines to contend with today
at Peppa let's start with you with the
front page the guardian catastrophic
thousands dared as earthquake hits
turkey and Syria and of course your
paper choosing a picture of Hope amid
the devastation where a little girl
being rescued
yes and unfortunately there was a few
stories of Hope
um over the course of the day I mean we
first heard about this stories we were
waking up here in the UK they're already
at that point been a very powerful 7.8
magnitude
um Quake which hit in the darkness
um the P Dawn and in southern turkey and
northward Northwest Syria and already at
that point there was hundreds of people
being reported uh to have been killed
unfortunately the toll increased over
the course of the day and obviously made
a lot worse by a second very strong
Aftershock 7.5
um on the Richter scale
uh which caused yet more Devastation to
these areas and you know we're at the
point already where I think it's about 3
800 so when the guardian went to print
but that was obviously
um already a couple of hours ago and
um sadly I think we're expecting to see
as as Rescuers and Rescuers and
residents search for survivors those
death tolls likely to rise uh still
higher it was that it was the uh most
powerful earthquake uh to hit the region
in at least a century you can see on the
front pages of the papers all of the
papers and of course in images that
you're showing there
some of the devastation that have been
caused uh the Turkish government
obviously has sent in immediate aid and
support rescue operations and countries
right across the globe including the UK
have um have offered I've offered expert
help I think the British UK is not
sending a team of 76 search and rescue
Specialists equipment and rescue dogs to
Turkey
um the the is even more difficult the
situation in in Northwest Syria because
as you'll know that is one the one sort
of Enclave of Syria where there's still
Rebels holding out fighting against the
Syrian regime Aleppo which has once a
commercial cap one of the big commercial
Capitals in Syria has been devastated by
War in recent years and there's been
appeals by the International Community
to the government in Damascus and their
moscow-based backers to stop uh to stop
the the bombing of uh of Aleppo and of
the region which is which has been a
constant in their lives
um over the last few years uh because of
this profound humanitarian disaster
um I don't know what the latest is on
that on the ground but um but absolutely
imperative of course about humanitarian
support and that rescue support gets
into that region in the way that it is
in southern turkey but is it still
ongoing tonight
um I don't know if there's going to be
any more there's expected to be any more
earthquakes because obviously there's
often aftershocks of earthquake of that
of that severity
um buildings which are ready already
fragile are potentially more even more
risk of
um of collapse uh causing more uh injury
and death
um and of course there's probably still
Many Many Bodies hidden under the rubble
amidst the only two rare moments of hope
that we've seen on some of the front
pages there's unfortunately going to be
a lot more Devastation and horror and
sadness
it really is Bleak is nipple and it's
very hard for us to come to come the
size or the enormity of the story faith
in these two countries um Harry let's
bring you in now to the front page of
the Metro they're choosing equally
another very powerful picture and as
Pippa says another picture of Hope
another little girl who has been rescued
amid the rubble but my word what a
powerful picture the Metro has got on
their front page tomorrow
yeah a powerful picture that a
photographer happened to be there I
imagine that scene is being hopefully
repeated across uh turkey and and Syria
as Pippa said the places we're not
seeing is is the more remote cut off uh
Northwest Syria where there isn't that
that media presence it isn't a built up
sort of connected part of the world
um it's one of those stories where sadly
the the sort of numbers are going up so
quickly but by the time that tomorrow's
papers are hitting newsstands in the
morning I suspect some of the first
editions will be quite wildly out of
date in the death toll uh we've lost
tonight as the sun
um an appeal for for our readers for for
the public to donate all the money will
be given to help the British Red Cross
um do what they do best which is is is
is fly towards the danger in these areas
um again yeah a striking pitch on the
front of the Metro but sadly I imagine a
very a pin prick compared to the
devastation across the region and Harry
whilst we're talking to you let's have a
look at the front page of the sun now
and you can tell us a little bit more
about the earthquake appeal that your
newspaper is launching and you the Sun
going with the headline 10 000 fear dead
in the rubble with many more trapped and
the same picture I see on the front page
the Sun as we saw earlier in the air
Guardian
no again British Red Cross all donations
will be channeled two getting support
getting not just raising support
domestically but getting helping people
on the ground the British government the
foreign office sent 76
um sort of rescue workers tonight I
suspect I understand that figure is
going to be increased quite dramatically
tomorrow
um again it's one of those situations
that you feel kind of helpless in that
but a 10 a tenor or 20 quid might just
um might just help out
um prepper onto the financial times they
they choose to lead of course with the
story as well as the usual business
coverage is going a bit further down the
front page there thousands dead after
biggest quake and 84 years shakes turkey
and Syria what do you make of their
coverage and their angle on it
well it's quite unusual that you get
um a story that doesn't have a an
obvious economic business or sometimes
political angle on the front page of the
financial times but this is clearly one
which is dominating papers from left to
right from Broad Street to tabloid as it
has done the uh the Airways over the
course of the day both on sky and
elsewhere
um it obviously is a huge disaster to to
hit the region now these are this is a
part of the world that is no stranger
sadly to
um two earthquakes um it's built on uh
obviously fault lines run underneath
um and unfortunately they they have had
many incidents um over the years but
this is a very very dramatic or this was
very very dramatic the most significant
I think it says that we're serious in 84
years the Ft says
um it's devoted its whole front page bar
a business story at the bottom too to
the um the rescue to the um the natural
disaster
um talks at 3 000 buildings just three
thousand Builders Builders may have been
destroyed across affected areas that the
Quake was initially felt as far away as
Lebanon and Cyprus
um and and and parts of Greece
um obviously very very profound and then
they give me then again makes the point
that some of the other papers have made
that
um there's a particular issue in Syria
where
um it's been very difficult to get the
sort of humanitarian immediate
humanitarian rescue a resource because
of the conflict that's um that's going
on there and that while there is the
Syria civil defense which is a group of
Western Backed Aid workers in the region
it's very difficult for other
governments for example
um to get in but yet it's the home to
4.6 million people the majority of whom
according to un require humanitarian Aid
before even the earthquake because
obviously uh of the ongoing War so you
know these are very desperate people
many of whom had fled after being
displaced um in Syria's Civil War and
they're living in informal settlements
sort of you know almost Shanty towns
built up uh which would be particularly
particularly vulnerable
um to the quake and you know there's
very little medical support there either
obviously that's the medical
infrastructure hospitals and surgeries
um and so on uh have been destroyed in
the war as well so it was a pretty
desperate place before even this Quake
is going to be particularly hard to get
support in there but it really feels
that there has to be some sort of
um some sort of agreement some sort of
ceasefire uh at least until
International Aid workers can get in to
try and help else it's going to be even
more desperate uh hospitals are ready
overwhelmed with patients and you know
disaster relief agencies already
humanitarian relief agencies are ready
at stretching point there it's going to
be even worse in the wake of this and it
really feels that there has to be some
sort of international pressure put on
Damascus to make sure that that extra
support can get in at this really very
difficult time indeed it's been
described today I think as a crisis
within a crisis and of course it's
bitterly cold there too so they had the
winter to come to end with as well Pippa
and Harry do you stay with us we're
taking a quick break now at plenty more
from Pippa and Harry as we go towards
the inside Pages as well as off looking
at the front pages there
um word tonight of a mini reshuffle in
uh we're shooting at's cabinet so Harry
and Pippa going to be back tell us more
when we come back after this short break
don't go away just stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me now is peppercareer and
Harry Cole welcome back to the program
thank you for staying with us
um let's have a look at how other
stories are being uh recorded or
reported I should say in the papers
tomorrow Harry let's go to your page
your paper I should say that's the Sun
and an exclusive you say a sunak shake
up PM's Rishi reshuffle I should say
changes could see ra bade knock and
shops move a breakup tip to create a
separate energy Department
um tell us more
well we've all known over the last eight
or nine days that richardsonette was
gonna have to make some minor changes to
his top team after he fired the deem
zahawi the the party chairman and
suspicions been growing as that times
have went on that actually he hadn't
appointed a new party chairman and now
tonight it sounds like tomorrow he's
going to make useless opportunity should
we say 100 just 100 days into his
Premiership to make some wider changes
to his uh to his cabinet now during the
leadership campaign last summer that
sunac lost he talks a lot about creating
this new Department of energy
um I understand he's been quite
unimpressed when he was Chancellor by
the scale of the business department
which obviously takes an industry skills
business energy sort of super
development is actually too big
um I think from memory it was created by
Theresa May in 2017 by bringing lots of
different departments together
and it sounds like we could be headed
back towards a more traditional sort of
Department of trade industry which was
emerging trade and business together and
then hiring off some of the culture
Department taking that digital brief
from culture and creating a sort of
skills and digital department and then a
separate Department of energy now what
that does mean is there's been a
knock-on effect of
um some cabinet changes I understand
tonight that Grant chaps isn't going to
be the new body chairman he'll be
staying in the ministerial role so I'm
tipping him tonight to be the business
and trade secretary which means Kenny
bad not could be moving around the
cabinet Now Kevin very popular with the
Grassroots
um a big risk if he was if the Prime
Minister was to put her into uh the the
party chairman role which is the job is
essentially going around the country and
talking to associations now if you're a
leadership Contender who's got their
eyes one day on The Party The Party
leadership that's almost your perfect
role if you want to build up an
alternative power base in um in the
conservative party so big big risks and
big advantages tonight for foreign if
you can pull this off but it sounds like
it's gonna be yet again another busy day
in Westminster tomorrow indeed let's
have a look at how the times is covering
this as well Pippa let's bring you in
now also on the front page as well of
course their coverage of the earthquake
in turkey and Syria they say sunak is
planning a white will shake up with a
cabinet which Shuffle they go on to say
one government Source says the reshuff
will be relatively limited another
suggests it could be more extensive so
they're kind of backing both horses it
seems here
yes and I think that goes through to the
heart of the uncertainty around this
tonight
um there's suggestions earlier as Harry
said that Grant chaps was going to be
tipped as party chair he of course was a
party chair I think it was from 2012 to
2015 was it Harry it was a period anyway
under under David Cameron um he'd
already been in the role and of course
had impressed uh Rishi sinak with his
grasp of a spreadsheet during his own
leadership campaign
um possibly uh you know not sure how key
that in particular skill is to being
party chair but you know he certainly
had the advantage of having done the job
before
um but as the time says it might just be
limited to the uh sort of the redrawing
of the department for business and
replacing Nadeem Sahari but there are of
course other headaches ahead for Rishi
sunakin that the inquiry into the
bullying allegations surrounding Dominic
Robb his Deputy Prime Minister and of
course the Justice secretary
um are still ongoing there's no
suggestion that that's going to likely
to be completed in the next well
probably the next couple of weeks
um it's likely to take slightly longer
than that
um and and Rishi senek has already uh
sort of uh doubled down on uh not
suspending him while that inquiry is is
going on so where he then turn around
and say actually you know we're going to
move you from post or you're going to be
suspended uh which means more questions
about his judgment and provide more
opportunities for the opposition to
accuse him of being weak so um he's got
a sort of a Sticky Sticky Wicket on that
one coming up as well so whatever he
decides to do tomorrow whether it's a
small V Shuffle or or a broader one
um if uh the inquiry into Dominic Robb
finds
um that he has broken the ministerial
code that he shouldn't remain in
position and vicious agrees with that
then we might yet see
um another reshuffle albeit a mini one
um further ahead
um at that point
um before in the run-up to Christmas
quite a few um in fact before that even
ever since Richardson took over there's
been a lot of suggestions amongst his
ministers that the cabinet that he put
in place when he first took over was
almost one of necessity that he had to
keep Jeremy Hunt in place because he
wanted to maintain the sort of you know
the stability and um to reassure the
markets
um once he took over from his trust that
he had to keep Suella bravaman
um because she sort of represented the
right of the party the sort of the ERG
the ERG core that he wanted to keep on
board
um equally having both Penny mordant and
Kimmy bad enough both of whom ran
against him and both in the First toy
leadership contest and both of him were
tipped as a potential Future Leaders
particularly of course Kimmy Baden
Osteen has been sort of a a great rising
star of the Tory Wright
um he had to put them all in his cabinet
to try and maintain that very fragile
Unity that was existing in the party
um if he if he now reshuffles
um more broadly he's going to have to
bear in mind
um that he's got to keep the different
factions together so even if he wants to
put more of his own people in there's
been for example suggestions that Oliver
died in would a very close Ally and Mel
stride and you might want to move them
to sort of more high profile roles or
bigger roles um he's going to be very
very capable careful to keep that very
delicate equilibrium that exists at the
moment in the cabinet uh if he doesn't
then he risks obviously ostracizing and
frustrating uh key groups in his back
benches that could cause him the
potential to cause him more trouble than
they already are doing talking of
causing trouble let's have a look at the
front page of the eye newspaper now of
course we know that Liz truss is uh
making a bit of a comeback hasn't she a
big article in the Sunday Telegraph this
weekend she's also been talking to
spectator TV tonight hasn't she Harry uh
the eye newspaper saying that her
comeback has damaged the Tories
according to pollsters what'd you make
of this
I haven't actually seen the the data on
this but it's a slight dog bites man
that uh that one isn't it it's the fact
that look divided parties don't win
elections
um is the age-old saying and it's clear
that Liz trust isn't going to go into
the night quietly she's sort of licked
her wounds for a hundred days
um and she's clearly while at the same
time sort of putting on a brave face and
saying that actually no you know she's
she's unrepentant in in a diagnosis and
her actions as prime minister
um also sort of trying to blame everyone
else so it's just another little
headache for her she said most prime
ministers have to deal with one
predecessor on the back benches Richie
sulak's got two predecessors both
jostling not one perhaps Boris Johnson
like sharing a bit of ankle probably not
really expecting to come back but likely
to keep the possibility open and this
trust is saying I don't want to come
back but I do want to wrestle the
ideological soul
of the conservative party away from sort
of decliners and managerialism sunachism
technocratic government and actually
almost looking forward to into
opposition and saying look who are we
what do we stand for as a party uh and
it's a debate which I've been saying for
for months now that if you really want
to have as as politicians the public I
think will probably rather you have in
opposition you can't rejuvenate the
party to that extent while remaining in
government and it just looks like cats
fighting in a sack because frankly
that's what it is okay let's give the
final word to Pippa before we see you at
the top of the hour again what do your
readers make of Liz truss's intervention
do you think
I think probably some amusement the fact
that we've had two major interventions
both in the Sunday Telegraph and then
again a spectator TV and at neither
moment was there any apology really for
the damage which she inflicted on the
economy and it's not just an abstract
thing for many people it's about their
mortgage interest rates going up as well
and this trust was quick to say well
that wasn't just because of what we did
in in government
um and you know I think a lot of her
peers feel that it really is now they're
not not the time for her to come back
I'm sorry to interrupt but we have to go
there but we will see you shortly